my number-6 choice in many respects
might be the most pathetic person on the
list but he might also be the most
badass person on the list its Marv from
Sin City this is probably the most
violent film I've ever seen and I don't
be violent as in gory although it's
definitely bad I mean that literally I
don't think there's a minute that goes
by without some form of violence being
committed it's just insane I don't think
there's 60 seconds without someone
getting punched or sliced or jabbed or
slapped or something so what would think
it's hard to get a lot of character
development in there
but in my opinion Marv is one of the
greats he's a deformed man that spends
most of his life living with his mom
getting drunk and just hanging out in
strip clubs not the most glamorous of
people but when a beautiful woman named
Goldie gives him the night of his life
and then is murdered the very same night
Marv finally has a purpose in life all
the insults all the drunkenness all the
loser traits he often associates with
himself suddenly mean nothing because
now he has something to live for and
more importantly die for he wants to
avenge the death of his ladylove simply
because she was the only one who was
ever nice to him and that's it
there's no other reason he didn't even
know anything about her he doesn't even
know what her personality was like but
she was the only one that even for a
moment gave him something that he never
even knew existed he spends the whole
entire movie just trying to avenge this
woman it's so simple and yet so perfect
that kind of dedication is hard not to
find fascinating it says so much about
what he's gone through in his life he
describes himself as so ugly as he
wasn't even able to buy a woman which I
don't know seem really that bad ladies
but the one thing that does shine
through is that he's an all-out action
star just look at these fight scenes and
he enjoys every minute of it because he
knows he finally has something to fight
for the All or Nothing days he describes
it he kills he mames he tortures he rips
apart but on the name of someone that
many people say doesn't deserve the
light of day as well in many respects
there's a great association there both
that to people
many would assume wouldn't amount to
anything but the fact that they crossed
paths went to this series of events and
managed to share even the most
animalistic of urges with each other
creates a passion and a dedication that
can't be destroyed and the more die
hardcore this guy goes with it the more
you appreciate his quest and that he
just never wants anything to get in his
way and the more you start to realize
nothing will get in his way
he's just unstoppable over something so
simple but it's the only thing he's ever
had in his life the only thing he would
ever describe is actually beautiful and
to him that's worth everything and on
top of that he's just so good at it look
at this guy in action
he is just awesome this is testosterone
bursting to the nth degree
yeah it's childish and unbelievably
comic-book ish but it's not the violence
that makes it interesting it's the
motivation and character it's the fact
that somebody who had nothing to live
for suddenly does and he's willing to go
all-out for it it's the fact that his
life suddenly has purpose and you can
identify with that because everybody has
gone through some point in their life
where they have felt worthless and they
want to bounce back and here's a guy
who's had most of his life just to that
but now he has meaning and he's not
gonna waste one more second of his once
worthless life not to live it out Marv
is a dedicated loser with it all on the
line to become one of my favorite
characters
you